With stunning coastlines and wilderness,...
...the natural beauty of the island of Molokai is unspoiled.
Known as the Friendly Isle,...
...Molokai is insulated from the hustle and bustle of everyday life...
...and is an idyllic island.
Kaunakakai on Molokai is a quiet town that remains as it was in the early 20th century.
One of Molokai's most notable spots is Kalaupapa Peninsula,...
...which is home to a National Historical Park of the same name.
The only ways to reach the park are by hiking,...
...by air or via a mule ride that lasts almost three miles.
Sea cliffs which overlook the Pacific Ocean on the island's North Shore...
...are the world's tallest sea cliffs,...
...and hold that place in the Guinness Book of World Records.
And don't forget the Kalaupapa Lookout,...
...which is just one place to take in the spectacular views.